what's up guys so as you guys already
know the GTX 10 series has been out for
a couple of years right now and with the
price being really high and the halting
of the production of GPU 102 we can
infer that the next series is coming out
in the imminent future but how will this
new car perform when will they come out
how much will they cost and most
importantly should you buy any of these
new cars first let's take a look at its
expected performance well these new
cards are expected to get a nice upgrade
to GD dr6 memory at speeds of 16
gigabits per second or 80 gigabytes per
second and this memory will be
manufactured by Samsung also these new
cards that are codenamed ampere are
thought to be produced in a 12 nanometer
architecture so what real-world upgrade
will these improvements bring well it's
really hard to say now because we don't
really know anything about what NVIDIA
is developing and how much they're
willing to give us so far I think it is
pretty clear that they won't give us
Volta with ampere and this will simply
be a Pascal refresh but that's not
necessarily a bad thing as long as the
performance is still good so what are
some good estimates I think that the
best way to predict the future is to
actually look at the past generational
gaps so last generation we saw that the
1060 was just about equal in performance
with the GTX 980 and the 1070 was just
about equal to the 980 TI if you go down
a little bit further we can see that the
1050 was equal to 960 in my opinion
those were some pretty significant
upgrades one of the top and 900 series
cars was literally equal to only the mid
level of the 1000 series so it was
really quite a nice so based off that
the GTX 2060 and 1080 being was really
not that far off so if that's true and
the 2070 and 1080 I should be equal and
so on and so forth
so hopefully this is what happens but
anything that 2070 should at least be as
powerful as a 1080 or else it's really
quite meaningless like 210 70 TI how
much performance do you think these
cards will bring make sure to post what
you guys are thinking
anyways we want a release date of these
cars rumors suggest NVIDIA will be
revealing these new series at the end of
March at GTCC and released the 27 in
2080 along with cheering on April 12th
while we haven't really had any solid
proof for this the fact that India has
stopped the production of a GPU want to
strongly alludes that there is a new
series of GPUs coming out very soon so
if anything we should be able to get our
hands on 2017 and 2018 by at least the
end of May so what about the GTX 2060
and 2050 well unfortunately I don't
think those will come out - until later
this year as in third or fourth quarter
it'll probably be out before holiday
season though because Nvidia knows that
they can make a lot of money then next
finally the flagship GTX 28t I probably
won't come out till the end of this year
or even next year so obviously there is
going to be some waiting if you are
interested in some of these cards but
there is no reason to wait for them if
the price is denied so how much will
these GPUs actually cost well there has
been this crazy rumor that 20/80 will
cost a whopping $1,500 which is even
more than current very overpriced gtx
1080p is is this really going to be the
case well in my opinion definitely not
and here is why it is it simply makes no
sense I know that Nvidia is a
corporation and they want to make as
much money as possible but it really
makes no sense for them to do this
miners will not be interested in these
cars because Nvidia's plenty a separate
series for them called tearing so they
will not really affect this so Nvidia
would just create a lot of hate for
themselves
if they made a move like that and
receive a lot of backlash from gamers
and so in the end they wouldn't really
sell too much because only some rich
gamers would be able to afford these if
you guys think that in video price to
die high because the current graphics
cards would be more expensive if they
didn't but then that also doesn't really
make too much sense because India
doesn't care anymore about previous
generation GPUs they already stopped the
production of GP one or two a while ago
so they are really not making any money
from the 10 series anymore because
nvidia has probably already sold their
cars to retailers or after mark
pew manufacturers so the price disparity
will really not be their problem also in
video would make much more money if they
offered their upcoming cards at a
reasonable price because there is also a
lot of gamers who I've been waiting for
months to be able to purchase a GPU
because they simply refuse to overpay or
they just can't afford it and as a
result it has a huge new market that is
willing to snatch these GPUs when they
can but like I said they won't pay
anything more than what the MSRP should
be so Nvidia would be losing out on a
lot of average gamers and the average
gamers who makes up the most of their
income so I doubt Nvidia would purposely
avoid them and be greedy and try to make
more money of each card while targeting
a much small demographic so does that
mean that these new GPUs will release
for the same MSRP as its predecessor
well the answer is asked question is
unfortunately not Nvidia simply has no
control over this aspect it's well known
that a ram is very overpriced right now
and of course graphics cards need Ren
and as a result the overpriced Ram will
carry into GPUs also being overpriced
and of course there's still a lot of
demand but this wouldn't lead to GPUs
doubling in price like what's happening
right now because that demand would
greatly be reduced by miners being taken
out of the picture so we can expect
something similar to what happened at
the 8700 K so overall I think that GPUs
will be about $200 over MSRP the gtx
1080 MSRP was $600 and if we assume that
2080 is the same way then I expected a
graphics card will be about $800 at
least shortly after release but I think
it'll go down $100 after the initial
high demand dies down and finally after
her RAM prices slowly returned to normal
and stabilized in the second half of
this year I expect that GPUs will return
to MSRP so here's the big picture I
believe at the release of these graphics
cards they will be about $200 over MSRP
but one to two months later it will drop
by $100 finally in the third or fourth
quarter of this year prices had finally
returned to MSRP so that's what I'm
thinking about the pricing situation
should you buy this well straight up I
strongly believe that if you're in the
market for a GPU then you should
definitely consider being patient and
just wait for the next year's instead of
buying a 10 series GPU because I really
think that it will be worth the wait as
a result I know you guys have been
waiting for a really long time but
seriously just push a bit further and
it'll be worth it you might even be able
to afford a higher level of GPU by
waiting and saving so please just wait a
little bit longer but that's pretty much
all I have for you guys this time make
sure to post what you guys are thinking
about this like when do you guys think
these graphics cards will come out and
what do you think they will be priced I
do read all my comments and I am curious
as to what you guys think so make sure
to post your thoughts also make sure to
drop a like on this video if you guys
found it informative and make sure to
hit that subscribe button if you would
like to see more videos like this but
I'll talk next time bye
[Music]